[Music]
after centuries of war the world's
kingdoms have come to an agreement every
five years teams representing the elves
goblins and Treefolk will compete in a
grand tournament of dragon jousting
every team will face each of the others
once the kingdom whose team wins the
most matches will rule all of center
realm until the next tournament to
prevent any outside meddling the games
are to be conducted in absolute secret
except for a group of wizards will make
sure nobody uses enchantments hexes or
spells to cheat you've been given the
extremely important job of recording the
scores for the first inaugural
tournament but the opening celebrations
get a bit out of control and when you
wake up you realize the games are
already underway
fortunately no one has noticed your
absence so far however you need to get
up to speed quickly if your boss the
head tournament official finds out
you've been sleeping on the job you'll
lose your head after weighing your
options you decide to offer your life
savings to one of the regulation wizards
in return for the information giving him
your blank scorecard to fill out but
before he can finish your boss walks
into the tent you barely managed to hide
the scorecard in time and the wizard
excuses himself your boss chuckles hope
you didn't believe anything Gore Box
been saying he's been cursed to tell
only lies even in writing anyway can you
believe how low-scoring the tournaments
been every team has played at least once
yet not a single match with a combined
score of more than five hits anyhow I'll
be back in a minute to review your
scorecard you laugh along and when he
leaves you look at the partially
completed card now knowing every single
number on it is wrong you've only got
one chance to save yourself so what's
the real score of each match
the incredible thing about this riddle
is that you can reach the solution
despite an almost complete lack of
correct information and that's possible
because knowing that something is false
is meaningful information in its own
right the first key is to realize that
no team will play more than two matches
since there are only two other teams so
if the elves didn't actually play one
match and the goblins didn't actually
play two the truth must be that the
elves played two and goblins played one
for the elves to have played two matches
they must have faced each of the other
teams once
and since goblins have only played one
match so far against the elves that
means the match between goblins and
Treefolk has not occurred yet we know
it's false that the Treefolk tied zero
matches which means they're about
against the elves must have tied we also
know that the elves won at least one
match and since they tied against the
Treefolk they must have beaten the
goblins but can we figure out the actual
scores let's start with the elf Treefolk
tie because no more than five total hits
were scored the final tally must have
been 0 0 1 1 or 2 2 but the Treefolk
must have scored some hits and it's
false that they only had one hit scored
against them the only option that leaves
is to two in the match between elves and
goblins the goblins must have scored at
least one hit and the elves score must
be two or more for them to have won the
match this leaves only a few
possibilities that add up to 5 or less
the elves couldn't have scored 3 so that
eliminates these two and their total
hits scored across both matches can't
add up to 6 so this one's out - so the
score must have been to one with one
match remaining you've managed to save
your job and your neck Gore back the
wizard may have lied but your deductive
skills quickly even to the score
interested in honing your deductive
skills even further try out brilliant
orc brilliant is a problem-solving based
platform that has over sixty courses in
math science and computer science
brilliance logic course features
interactive components that bring
puzzles to life they let you manipulate
the elements as you solve them so you
get to develop your riddling skills
while having lots of fun visit brilliant
org slash ted-ed to check it out as an
added bonus the first eight hundred
thirty three of you to visit using that
link will receive 20% off the annual
premium subscription fee